attendre l'aval de l'agencé européenne
des médicaments avant de se tourner vers
le spoutnik v voilà ce qui semble être
la stratégie de l'union européenne
mais depuis quelques semaines des
régions au coeur des 27 ne veulent plus
attendre est celle qui a de la bavière
en allemagne hollande annonce avoir
négocié un contrat préliminaire en vue
de recevoir deux millions et demi de
doses du vaccin russe
même constat en espagne est la région de
madrid annonce avoir négocié avec moscou
en déplacement au sénégal le chef du
gouvernement a tenu à rappeler la
stratégie espagnole
nous allons poursuivre la vaccination
avec astrazeneca à partir de 60 ans si
spoutnik est homologué par le m a bien
entendu nous pourront inclure ce vaccin
dans le portefeuille des vaccins mais il
faut que ce vaccin soit homologué cela
n'a pas encore été le cas
nombre de l'union européenne la
slovaquie a passé commande auprès de
moscou est réceptionné une partie des
doses dès le mois dernier de son côté le
petit état de saint-marin utilise tout
nick v depuis début mars le pays non
membres de l'union européenne espère
ainsi pallier les retards de livraison
des vaccins occidentaux le but atteindre
rapidement l'immunité collective
aujourd'hui près d'un tiers de la
population est vaccinée et la cadence
devrait dans les jours à venir
s'accélérer l'objectif est d'atteindre
l'immunité collective d'ici la fin du
mois de mai donc l'objectif est de
concentrer toutes nos ressources puisque
nous avons vu qu'avec le variant
britannique
la contagion est élevé elle l'est aussi
chez nous évidemment les effets de la
vaccination sont visibles puisque l'âge
moyen des personnes infectées a baissé
mais l'objectif est de conclure la
campagne de vaccination avant la fin du
mois de mai en europe spoutnik v fait
l'objet d'une procédure par l' agence
européenne des médicaments depuis le 4
mars dernier il a fallu plus d'un mois
pour accréditer les sérums fader et
moderna et près de quatre mois pour
l'astra zeneca concernant spoutnik v des
conclusions pourraient être rendues
d'ici la fin du mois de juin prochain